تماما مثل ما حدث مع ماسه اميني السيناريو
نفسه يعاد لكن الضحيه هذه المره متظاهر من
اقليه البلوش يدعى ابراهيم ريقي
حينها تعددت الروايات بخصوص مقتل ماسه
اميني انكار ثم اقرار بوفاه داخل قسم
الشرطه فصدور لتقرير نفى تعذيبها على يد
شرطه الاخلاق عكس الصور المسربه التي كشفت
تعرضها للضرب القصه تعاد بحبكه مطابقه
تماما مصادر اعلاميه ايرانيه قالت ان
الضحيه اعتقل من قبل الشرطه وتعرض للضرب
داخل المخفر قبل وفاته نتيجه الاصابات
قاضي شعبه القتل الخاصه والطبيب الشرعي
اكد وفاه ابراهيم ريقي بسبب الضرب الذي
تعرض له داخل مخفر الشرطه رقم 12 الشرطه
اعلنت ان الحادثه وقع خارج مخفرها لكن
مندوبي الطب الشرعي وبعد فحص الجثه
وملاحظتهم ان ملابس الضحيه ممزقه اكدوا
انه توفي نتيجه اعتداء وقع بعد نقله الى
المخفر
المنظمه العفو الدوليه اكدت من جانبها ان
هناك ادله تؤكد وفاته بسبب التعذيب اثناء
احتجازه من قبل الشرطه هي حكايه جديده
قديمه في قائمه تضم اسماء من تمت تصفيتهم
بسبب معارضتهم للنظام او فقط تجراوا على
الخروج للاحتجاج رجل الدين البلوشي عبد
الغفار نقشبندي حذر السلطات من عدم تعلم
الدرس ما لم يتم الكشف عن العناصر الامنيه
التي تسببت بمقتل ريجي منبها الى ان
العواقب ستكون مشابهه في اشاره للاحتجاجات
بلال الوجداني العربيه